schönen tag meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren lieber scholli wir sehen uns
dieser tage ja fast täglich in paris vor
gestern in brüssel am wochenende in
münchen eigentlich mehr als unsere
ehepartner das wäre in guten zeiten ein
schönes signal in diesem zeichen ist es
gut dass wir uns oft treffen aber hat
leider einen wirklich nicht erfreulichen
grund nichtsdestotrotz oder umso mehr
ist ein heutiger besuch heute hier in
berlin was ganz besonderes du hast heute
in der sitzung unseres kabinetts
teilgenommen 's des neuen kabinetts der
neuen deutschen bundesregierung
und damit sehr sichtbar gemacht wie tief
und wie eng die freundschaft und
partnerschaft zwischen frankreich und
deutschland ist als im
deutsch-französischen nach einer vertrag
von 2009/10 dieser regelmäßige
wechselseitige kabinetts besuch
vereinbart wurde geschah dies im
bewusstsein der europäischen
nachbarschaft im bewusstsein dass wir
unsere gemeinsame zukunft nur
gewinnbringend und vor allen dingen nur
freundschaftlich gestalten können wenn
wir auf ewig zusammenarbeiten die ihf
möchte ich dafür ausdrücklich danken
dass du konsequenz im geiste dieses
aachener vertrags handelt und sich
unermüdlich für die deutsch französische
freundschaft einsetzt in worten wie in
taten wir können uns in guten wie in
schlechten zeiten immer aufeinander
verlassen und arbeiten vertrauensvoll
zusammen dass es in der heutigen zeit
nicht nur sehr wertvoll sondern es ist
alles andere als selbstverständlich
unsere zusammenarbeit und auch unser
zusammenhalt sind umso wichtiger weil
wir als europa als wert mehr innen als
internationale gemeinschaft in der
russland krise gerade von der regierung
in moskau auf die probe gestellt werden
der russische präsident versucht im
osten der ukraine
das rad der geschichte auf kosten seiner
nachbarn zurückgehen mit macht mit
militär mit absoluter verachtung
gegenüber all dem was die rechts und
friedensordnung in europa ausmacht und
nicht zuletzt auch mit gleichgültigkeit
gegenüber
die regierung in moskau in den
vergangenen wochen monaten immer wieder
vor den folgen gewarnt und zwar in enger
abstimmung und gleich lang wir sind
bilateral immer wieder im gespräch
gewesen aber vor allen dingen gemeinsam
in der eu in der nato in der g 7 in der
osze und in anderen gesprächs kann ihren
diese einigkeit setze ich nun auch im
handeln fort in enger abstimmung mit
unseren partnern haben wir als eu ein
gezieltes und hartes funktionspaket
beschlossen diese sanktionspaket nimmt
jede unternehmen banken und vor allen
dingen personen in den fokus die an
dieser erneuten verletzung der
ukrainischen souveränität beteiligt sind
gleichzeitig schränken wir die fähigkeit
russland ein geld an den kapitalmärkten
aufzunehmen und dieses paket kann
jederzeit weiter verschärft werden
zusätzlich war es uns als
bundesregierung sehr wichtig auch auf
nationaler ebene zu zeigen für eine
freie souveräne und demokratische
ukraine nehmen wir wirtschaftliche
folgen in kauf
frieden und freiheit in europa haben
kein preisschild
deswegen haben wir entschieden die
zertifizierung von nord stream zwei zu
stoppen meine position zu diesem projekt
kennen sie bereits nur zu gut umso
wichtiger war es mir umso wichtiger war
es uns dass wir jetzt wo wir uns in
einem neuen spiel mit russland befinden
die konsequenzen für das projekt
deutlich deutlich aufzuzeigen und vor
allen dingen diese konsequenzen jetzt
auch voll durchzuziehen
lieber jean yves ihr habt im moment die
europäische ratspräsidentschaft immer
und sie steht unter dem leitmotiv die
europäische souveränität zu stärken wir
haben in den letzten tagen gezeigt dass
es dabei nicht nur um leere worthülsen
geht sondern um konkretes handeln im
interesse der europäischen sicherheits
ordnung dafür danke ich dir von herzen
und ebenso für deinen heutigen besuch
des ebooks
anna lena nur wo häufig timo
toyota fiel der truppe die
tresore der trolle premier
war
frostig
also das war die rede vorne annalena
baerbock der deutschen außenministerin
versuchen wir's einzuordnen mit
bildpolitik chef jan schäfer der hier
bei uns im studio ist ja du hast
zugehört hat eifrig mitgeschrieben was
sind die entscheidung
also annalena baerbock hat noch einmal
deutlich gemacht hast die sanktionen die
gestern beschlossen wurden und über
deren härte und schärfe man streiten
kann auf jeden fall nicht das ende der
fahnenstange sind sondern da geht noch
mehr das hat sie deutlich gemacht und
ganz klar auch nochmal den appell an
wladimir putin gerichte und gesagt also
fangen nicht an jetzt doch in die
ukraine einzumarschieren denn wir können
das rad was wir gerade drehen die
sanktionsschraube noch deutlich schärfer
machen und deutlich anziehe und er hat
auch gesagt dass frieden und demokratie
oder frieden und freiheit in europa kein
preisschild besitzen natürlich besitzt
ein preisschild denn am ende muss ja
auch die verteidigung des friedens und
der freiheit etwas gibt es ja nicht
umsonst das kostet etwas aber sie wollte
das anders darstellen wollte sagen wir
werden nicht darauf schauen was die
verteidigung von frieden und freiheit
kostet sondern werden das fazit man kann
fast sagen koste es was es wolle in
jedem fall immer so tun dass wir frieden
und freiheit verteidigen mein eindruck
ist ein bisschen aber dass wenn putin so
weitermacht wie es in den vergangenen
tagen und wochen ja gemacht hat auch
dieser appell leider gottes verhallen
wird das ist gesagt sie hat genau gesagt
wir nehmen finanziellen schaden in für
diesen frieden ist es nicht auch so ein
bisschen so dass das jetzt auch auf dem
rücken der bürger ein wenig hier bei uns
in deutschland auch ausgetragen wird
stichwort verbraucher die ganzen preise
steigen gas heizkosten werden enorm
teuer benzinkosten werden wahrscheinlich
in die höhe schnellen genau das ist
glaube ich der punkt den sie so nicht
meinte so wie sie es gesagt aber
ich meine es natürlich auch verstehen
können ja und es ist natürlich auch ein
großes thema zumindest jetzt hier bei
uns in deutschland wo mit ganz klar und
das was annalena baerbock sagt ist dass
die verteidigung
kein preisschild hat in dem sinne wir
müssen sie immer verteidigen koste es
was es wolle eigentlich aber ganz klar
ist und das haben ja andere
regierungsmitglieder unter anderem ihr
parteifreund robert habeck gestern auch
dargestellt und schon gesagt dass
natürlich wir uns auch was das angehen
muss energiepreise heizöl benzin gas auf
steigende kosten werden einstellen
müssen das ist immer so gerade in
krisensituationen der ölpreis gestern
drauf geschossen siebeneinhalb
jahreshoch dass es verunsicherung an den
märkten die man sieht aber die man weiß
ja ob russland beispielsweise in einem
angriffsfall also in russland jetzt
stärker in die ukraine einmarschiert im
kriegsfall sozusagen dann auch wirklich
an den gastwirten festhält oder ob es
möglicherweise weniger gas gibt und dann
steigen die preise natürlich noch stand
jan schäfer ganz herzlichen dank danke
für deine in ordnung